[Musique]
on promet cette jument c'est dégueulasse
ça va pas non et renvoie sa mère
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui vous amène brève
tenez votre contrat j'ai une condition
je le pouvais remonter un choc pour moi
ici on fait du dressage du bon niveau
des choix allemand j'ai toujours voté le
show de même boulot partout on tue par
un boulot les bons choix pour les autres
comme dan avance foulé l'avant au
protègent nos femmes des jambes bien vu
qu'il n'est pas cassé ce cheval
j'ai pas grand chose vous leur entrée
vous allez faire l'inventaire des
clôtures on va les niveaux avant de
travailler avec franz mann vous les
emmenez tout son ami ali pou fé la wii
au concours d'un gros business qui monte
les autres pendant notre absence
personne non personne n'en est pas là je
leur dis ce que tu as maté le cheval
quand ils reviendront ses seins bazire
est un esclave
[Musique]
ne manquez pas d'air oui je porte
plainte pour vol semaine tous les
pouvoirs je veux faire la compétition
avec vous parce qu'il faut modèles vont
venir chercher le cheval est ta petite
aventure ça va terminer on peut savoir
ce qui se passe
des sans aucun à son 7 1 canaux 100
quand on aura d'autres
[Musique]